MALE SPEAKER: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming out.
Today we welcome Joel Stein.
[APPLAUSE]
JOEL STEIN: Is that weird?
Is that not what people do?
I haven't done this
that many times.
MALE SPEAKER: You might
know Joel from--
JOEL STEIN: Sitting here.
MALE SPEAKER: --his columns
in "Time" magazine.
Also, he's the guy
right over there.
Also from various TV
shows where he--
right after this he'll be going
to MSNBC to discuss
about important things,
I'm sure.
JOEL STEIN: With an audience
about this size.
MALE SPEAKER: His book is "Man
Made." He will teach us about
being manly, as someone who
grew up reading books and
played with computers probably
needs to learn more about.
So Joel Stein.
[APPLAUSE]
JOEL STEIN: No, I already
did that for you.
This may be the only group on
the planet I could teach
something about being
manly to.
So yeah, this will
work out well.
I write for "Time" magazine.
The only beat I cover is myself
because it's the only
thing I'm interested in.
And no one was covering
that beat.
I got there in 1997.
I was writing for a magazine
called "Time Out New York,"
and this editor at "Time" asked
me to write a piece for
this quarterly they did called
"Time Digital," back when
people-- like the internet
was new and people were
excited about it.
You had a lot more magazines
like "Red Herring" and
"Business 2.0."
And so I went to Kansas City and
Minneapolis, to find the
world's greatest video
game player.
And I'd never been on a
business trip before.
I was like barely old enough to
rent a car, which they make
impossible until you're like
30 for some reason.
And I remember sitting in my
hotel room having to write it
that night.
It was due the next day, and
just freaking out, like
writing for anything that
"Time" magazine put
out seemed so scary.
And I was just panicked.
And I couldn't write.
And I drove around Minneapolis
for a while.
I got to a Steak 'n Shake.
I drove in.
I was just going to get an ice
tea or something, and I went
up to the drive-through box.
And the woman said,
can I help you?
And I said, yeah, I just
really want to talk.
And she said, OK.
And so I told her my problems.
I had this story to write.
It's for "Time" magazine.
I keep picturing 4 million
people reading it.
And she gave me the most amazing
pep talk, which was
like, they wouldn't have hired
you if they didn't think you
could do it.
You've done this before.
Don't get in your
head so much.
And it was so incredibly
helpful.
And I drove up and I--
we didn't have the connection
I kind of hoped we'd have.
It's one thing when
you're talking to
someone through a box.
And then you see--
I thought she'd be
my future wife.
And it didn't work out.
But I did go home
and I wrote it.
I went to the hotel
A couple months later, I got
hired by "Time" magazine,
which freaked me out.
Because I thought I'd have to
write super boring stuff for
the rest of my life.
But they were paying me in real
money instead of in food,
which is what I was getting paid
at "Time Out New York."
Which I think you get paid--
do they pay you in food or they
also you a salary here?
Because I would do it
just for the food.
But that's why I'm
a journalist and
you guys are engineers.
So I've been working at
"Time" since '97.
And what I've found is that the
best way for me to learn
things is by doing things.
So when I write about something,
even if it doesn't
go in the article, even if the
article's all in third person,
I usually go do something
to understand it.
Like I recently wrote a profile
of Steve Ells, the CEO
of Chipotle.
And I kind of thought
I got him.
I thought I got the company.
But then they got the company
to let me work at a Chipotle
for half a day.
And then I kind of really got
what they were telling me.
It's really hard for me,
although I did fine in school,
to learn any other way.
So that's kind of how I got
to writing this book.
And kind of how I do most of my
stories in "Time." I had to
do a cover on George Clooney.
And I didn't know-- like
sitting down with
him seemed so boring.
So I invited him over my house
for dinner thinking he would
say no, but just so it would buy
me time to think of more
interesting things.
And he said yes.
At which point, I had to tell
my wife that George Clooney
was coming over for dinner,
which if anyone has a normal
wife and a normal
relationship--
I forgot this is on YouTube.
If anyone has a wife who
occasionally Googles her husband--
my wife doesn't care.
This is fine.
Yeah, she was pissed.
She was like, I have
to clean the house
and make like a playlist.
Like you're cleaning it and
you're making dinner.
I'm like, yeah, of course.
So she got drunk and so
did George Clooney.
And she spent a half hour just
grilling him on why he doesn't
have a wife, which I was
so happy about, just
taking crazy notes.
And didn't make it in
the piece, my editor
kept cutting it.
I kept putting it back in and
my editor kept cutting it.
But yeah, so there is video.
I find that the things I do,
because some of them--
I think because journalists
lie all the time, people
assume that I'm lying.
So I've taken to, if I
ever can remember.
And it's easier now when I have
my Google Android phone
in my pocket.
I shoot video whenever I can.
Like when Clooney was over, this
alarm started going off.
I just figured I'd ignore it
because that's what I do when
alarms go off.
And he had been a handy man.
He's like, no, we're
going to fix this.
Let's figure out where this
alarm's coming from.
So he wound up looking
all over my house.
He went under my house
and got this ladder,
way under my house--
I live in the Hills.
And then he brought it and went
into my attic, which I
now call the Clooney
attic, because I've
never been in there.
I still haven't been in there.
And he went up there
with a flashlight,
a little bit drunk.
And so I videotaped
all of this.
It turned out under our table
was a monoxide alarm.
It just needed a new battery,
which we figured out
eventually.
We would have got there
much earlier if
we hadn't been drinking.
But I videotaped it.
And now people who read this
story don't think believed he
was in my attic, but
you see the video.
So for the book, I tried to
videotape as much of me
getting beat up as I could, so
that people would believe it.
So for the book, I found out--
my wife was pregnant.
And we were going to the first
sonogram where we could
probably tell if it was
a boy or a girl.
And I remember thinking
that I don't care if
it's a boy or girl.
I'm a child of the '70s.
I understand both genders
are lovely.
I've enjoyed both-- that's
weird to say.
Totally straight.
I couldn't be more straight.
Do I find some men attractive?
Sure, we all do.
But I've never gone to second
base with a guy, ever.
Leave it there.
So I thought I didn't care.
Went to get the sonogram
and they told us that
our son was a boy.
In fact, our OB/GYN who I will
not name is amazing, super
cool, super smart women,
went to Princeton.
Just super smart.
But when she gave us the--
when you go to a sonogram now,
you get the equivalent of like
a photo booth strip of pictures
of your child.
And she said to us,
it's a boy.
Wow, he's got a really
big penis.
If things don't work out for him
in school, he can always
work in the Valley.
And like, this is
all so weird.
I'm just processing
information.
She gives us this photo strip.
She draws like a penis and
testicles and writes, wow,
exclamation point next to it.
And all I'm thinking is, we need
a new OB/GYN for sure.
But I'm also having like a
mini-panic attack where I'm
freaking out because
I'm picturing--
all I can picture
is that penis.
And that penis wanting
to throw a baseball.
to go camping.
And that penis getting
in a fight, needing
to know how to fight.
And I like, I'm not capable
of any of that stuff.
When I was a kid, all my
friends were girls.
I listened to nothing but show
tunes until I was like 13.
I had a glass animal
collection.
I had an Easy Bake Oven, which
I still think is awesome
because you can make
cakes in your room.
But a lot of other
boys didn't.
I never went camping.
I never played Little League.
I just thought, my son's going
to want to do all this stuff
and I'm not going
to be able to.
So I went out and tried to learn
all the things I should
have learned long before this.
I went on a series of what
I call manventures.
And the first thing I did was
I figured I'd fix the first
problem, which was not
becoming a Boy Scout.
So I called the Boy Scouts and
they said I could, indeed,
earn my first badge.
And so I went on a camping
trip for a weekend with
11-year-old Boy Scouts.
And put up my first tent
and slept in it.
I learned the difference between
sleeping in a tent and
sleeping just not in a
tent doesn't exist.
I don't know who the tent
industry has fooled.
But it's still cold.
It's wet when you lay.
I either had the wrong tent or
everyone else is an idiot.
So I went on a bunch of
these adventures.
Let's see.
I did so many things that I've
blocked out of my head because
they are painful.
I got a day trader to give me
$100,000 to day trade with of
his money for a day
in Chicago.
I worked in a pit crew of a
racing team, the America Le
Mans racing.
Team I had a Lamborghini
Superleggera for 3 days, which
was incredibly fun.
I helped my very manly
father-in-law fix a house,
re-roof and do some
plumbing work in a
house for three days.
I went turkey hunting.
Have any of you ever gone
turkey hunting?
I'm at Google.
I'm asking silly questions.
Have any of you ever played a
video game in which turkey
hunting takes place?
AUDIENCE: "Duck Hunt."
JOEL STEIN: "Duck Hunt."
That's close.
I, too, have played "Duck
Hunt." Turkey hunting is
totally different than
"Duck Hunt."
So I had this crush on a girl
from kindergarten to fifth
grade named Bizzy Sklars.
Very worthwhile crush.
And In fact, nothing to
do with this story,
just want to brag--
after college, kissed
her at a bar.
A bar called The
Village Idiot.
Only time I've ever kissed
a woman at a bar.
Village Idiot.
It closed now.
Yeah, I think it was owned by
the same people that own
Coyote Ugly, perhaps.
Yeah.
But anyway, I kissed
Bizzy Sklars there.
Wrote it on the wall.
Didn't write it on the wall,
wrote it in my book.
And so Bizzy did not
want to marry me.
She wound up marrying a very
manly dude up in Vermont who
built the extension on the log
cabin they live in by chopping
down the trees in his backyard
himself, and like
putting the logs in.
And his house is just
dead animals on the
wall that he's killed.
And I remember I walked
into their house.
I'd never been up
there before.
Because I came up to go turkey
hunting with them.
And there were like three
deer on the wall.
And I was like, oh, you
killed them all?
He's like, yeah, I wanted one
that I shot with with a rifle,
one I shot with a muzzle
loader, and one
I shot with a crossbow.
I was like, I don't
want to do this.
To go hunting--
I'm pretty socially liberal.
And to go hunting, turns out
you have to pass a test and
get a license.
It's like a 12-hour class,
then you take a test.
And I was like, I'm just going
hunting for one day with a
trained guy.
I still have to take
this test?
And they looked at me like I
was crazy when I called.
Or they said I was crazy.
Of course you have to take a
test, you're going to have a
gun in your hands.
And I had moved further right
than the NRA in about five
minutes of wanting to go hunting
than I ever thought I
could possibly move.
So to turkey hunting, just
in case anyone ever
invites you, don't go.
You have to wake up--
like with all male activities,
you have to wake up
at like 4:00 AM.
Because guys go and play
poker at night
and go to strip clubs.
Guys are out until 2:00 and
they wake up at 4:00.
Sleeping is not manly was the
first lesson I learned.
And for turkey hunting, it turns
out I don't like animals
enough to kill them.
Because you have to get really
involved in animal life.
To kill a turkey, you have to go
out in the woods, hide, not
move, wear camouflage, and
pretend you're a female turkey
who desperately wants
to get laid.
So you have to learn like what
a sexy turkey would sound
like, how to determine other
actual female sexy turkeys,
and get in like arguments with
them that you're going to be a
better turkey blow job giver
to your turkey man.
I think eating meat is wrong.
Except for turkey because
turkeys are the worst people
in the world.
Turkeys--
honestly, this is what a male
turkey does in the morning.
He goes out, has sex with as
many females as he can, and as
soon as a less alpha turkey
comes along, he beats them up,
and makes them stand
there and watch.
During mating season, that's
a turkey morning.
They just have sex until quote
unquote-- from Matt, Bizzy's
husband, they have quote, "They
have sex until their
peckers hurt." That's
their morning.
So we went out and Matt sat--
I held the gun and Matt sat next
to me and tried to be a
sexy turkey.
And he gets really into it, like
making sexy turkey faces.
And I just thought, this is--
I'm not manly enough to even
be comfortable with
what's going on.
And after turkey hunting,
I got the--
so I figured I had to do
something military related.
And I thought about
embedding in Iraq.
And my wife thought about me
not embedding in Iraq.
I didn't want to embed Iraq.
And I thought when you embed,
you kind of just watch anyway.
I wanted to do something
more experiential.
So I called someone at
Department of Defense and I
said, would any of the branches
let me do like three
days of boot camp somewhere?
And the next thing I know, every
branch of the military
was emailing me better and
better offers to compete to
have me use up our nation's
resources.
And so it got crazier
and crazier.
I was going to do something--
I did do something
with the Marines.
I was talking to the Navy.
The Army--
this General Mark Hurtling--
General--
started emailing me jokes.
He started emailing me
like, I heard you're
talking to the Navy.
I thought you wanted to learn
how to be a real man.
Smiley face.
And I was like, I want to be in
the branch of the military
where the generals
use emoticons.
That's my branch.
So I did some stuff with the
Marines, but the real stuff I
did was with the Army.
And again, rhetorical
question.
Have any of you served
in the military?
Really?
What'd you do?
AUDIENCE: Air Force.
JOEL STEIN: How long were
you in the Air Force?
AUDIENCE: I was [INAUDIBLE].
JOEL STEIN: So do you have a
job here or you just take
people's lunch money?
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: That's what
I do, generally.
JOEL STEIN: Yeah, because
they don't need it.
AUDIENCE: No one has lunch
money because it's free.
JOEL STEIN: They probably
don't mind.
AUDIENCE: Screwed that one up.
JOEL STEIN: Wow.
Did you all know that?
I figured that would be
something everyone at Google
knew that someone served.
He will protect you when
things go badly here.
So boot camp is really
stressful, like they yell at
you all the time.
When you eat, you
can't look up.
And if you look up,
they yell at you.
You don't talk to each other.
This is true in the Marines,
but it's also true in the
Army, I went to go do the
swimming test in the Marines.
And they made me take off my
clothes, which was weird
because they were dressed.
And then they made me walk
through these very Baden-Baden
kind of showers that I
had to walk through.
And then they made me urinate.
And this guy stood and yelled
in my ear and counted down
from 30 while I urinated.
And I was like, oh, they yell
at you while you piss, like
that's stressful.
And then he got to zero and i
didn't know what to do because
I still had a good stream going
and he just started
counting again from 10.
So I don't know what the
consequences were, but it was
scary at shit, like just someone
screaming in your ear
while you piss.
And basically, it's just getting
screamed at constantly
because everything
you do is wrong.
So I had only been in
my fake boot camp--
They let me do it with
a real troop.
It was kind of real,
but I knew I could
leave at any time.
I was 39 years old.
I wasn't like away from home
for my first time.
But it was really stressful,
like the way that a haunted
house is stressful. even though
it's fake, it still
feels real because someone's
really yelling at you.
And so I'm staling telling
you the fact that I was
only three hours in.
I hadn't done any physical
activity.
It was super hot.
And I hadn't really slept
because I was nervous the
night before.
And they made me eat
this cold MRE.
I fainted three hours in
without having done any
physical activity.
I've never fainted before.
Never fainted after.
But if any of you go into the
military, my advice is faint
right away.
Because the tenor changes
immediately.
I had Pedialyte, and a
fan, and a doctor.
And I was treated--
throughout the whole experience,
I was treated a
little bit better.
Yet, even like there's this
thing called the night
infiltration course,
which is amazing.
They wait until it
gets dark out.
So you're just waiting
and waiting.
And then they have these
speakers that blast the Muslim
call to prayers, which if
you're in a US military
uniform, I don't care if you are
Muslim, it's the scariest
thing in the world.
And then they play women
and children screaming.
And then they make you get into
a low crawl and crawl
towards these towers that are
shooting actual live machine
gun fire right over your head.
So you don't stand up.
You keep crawling.
It was one of the most amazing
things I've done my life
because I'm not a very
focused person.
I don't, as you know,
don't play sports.
But when people are shooting
live real machine gun fire
over your head, you really
are in the moment.
Every so often they
fire a flare.
And the idea was you had to stay
completely still, so that
you wouldn't be seen by the
enemy, which was actually some
private somewhere shooting
a machine gun at you.
And the sky lights up and
you have to stay still.
It was one of the most oddly
peaceful moments of my life.
Because there was nowhere
else I could possibly
be or think to be.
And it was amazing.
And I got to the end where
you're supposed to stand up
and I didn't stand up.
I kept going.
But eventually I stood up.
I was kind of proud of myself.
I had survived and done like a
decent job of telling other
people to go away from these
TNT areas that were
exploding near us.
They were fenced off, but
still they were loud.
And I got to the end and these
people came over to me and
they're like, we're doctors.
Are you OK?
We heard you fainted
earlier today.
And I realized that if I ever
was in the military, that's
all I'd be known for for
my entire career.
I'd be carrying POWs over my
shoulders and they'd be barely
alive and mocking me for
being the guy that
fainted during boot camp.
So the military's out for me.
And then finally, I decided
part of my problem was I'm
afraid of confrontation.
So I decided that really, being
afraid of confrontation
taken to the extreme is being
afraid of getting in a fight.
So I decided I needed
to get into a fight.
And I didn't know
how to do that.
Do you go to a bar and insult
someone's woman, like I had no
idea how to get into a fight.
So I did what all
wimpy guys do--
journalists at least when they
want to do something, is I
called a publicist.
And I called the publicist for
the UFC and I said, I would
like to fight one of your
fighters, knowing they'd say
no because they have lawyers.
And they don't make you sign
NDAs as soon as you walk into
a room, but they do
have lawyers.
And the publicist said,
that's a great idea.
We will let you fight
Randy Couture.
And I googled Randy Couture and
I thought, this is not a
good idea at all.
I couldn't back out though,
because the whole point was I
was afraid of confrontation, so
backing out seemed like a
horrible idea.
So I went and trained with
Dana White, who's the
president of the UFC, and he set
up some training for me.
And one of the things
he did was that--
I did videotape, so that people
could believe it.
Is he had this jujitsu black
belt guy with me.
He said, the first I want you
to do, dude, you got to get
choked out.
And so I said, I just want to
learn how to defend myself.
I don't know if I have to
experience the worst of it.
He's like, dude, you got to
know what it's like to get
choked out.
So he had this guy take off
his shirt, oddly, and get
behind me--
as if this wasn't gay enough--
and choke me out.
And he had never choked out
a total pussy before.
So he didn't know that I would
immediately, in the situation,
instead of trying to fight him,
which I knew was useless,
I just wanted to get
it over with.
So I tried to go to sleep.
And I was just trying to help.
I am an awesome actor,
apparently.
And they thought
I fell asleep.
And the next thing I know, Dana
White is yelling in my
face, dude, did you dream?
I was like, did I dream?
He's like, yeah, you dream.
It's crazy.
I don't think you
were choked out.
Let's do it again.
So I was like, no, no, no.
And the guy chokes
me out again.
And again, I'm fake sleeping.
And again, he's fooled.
And my voice and my throat is
so sore, like that night I
couldn't swallow my own spit.
Now I know why men for eons
have been such dicks.
Because if you have a really
miserable, hard physical day,
I couldn't talk.
I couldn't smile.
I was just an unhappy zombie,
which is how I imagine men
come home from like mining as.
My wife was like, you can't--
this was the day before
I was supposed
to fight Randy Couture.
And she's like, you can't
do that tomorrow.
Part of being a man is
knowing when to quit.
I was in enough of a daze where
I was like, yeah, that
makes sense.
Like anything you say right
now would make sense, like
being a man is knowing how
to arrange flowers.
Anything would've made sense.
And so I woke up the next
morning and this
fog had kind of lifted.
My throat still killed, but
I was able to function.
So I went and I fought
Randy Couture.
I met him thinking I would charm
him and that he would
know not to hurt me.
But he would not talk to me.
He just like pointed.
And we went to this ring.
I was so, so scared.
But I was hoping it would
be over in five seconds.
He would either hit me
and I would blackout.
Or he would get me into some
kind of hold and it would end.
But instead, Randy Couture
decided to go at like 10% and
let me know what five minutes
in the ring felt like.
And he would just toy with me
and kind of knock me down,
then let me go and knock
me down and let me go.
I don't recommend this
as an experience.
But after doing all this stuff,
I realized that there's
a lot of it I didn't like.
And that genetically, there's
just some stuff I'm
predisposed not to like.
I don't have the kind of
detailed attention span for
some of the stuff.
I do fix stuff around my
house now, really minor
stuff that I YouTube.
Some of it's so much easier
than you think, and it
impresses my wife, and
it gets me laid.
So if fixing a toilet will get
me laid and it takes a half
hour, I will fix a toilet.
And it does make you feel good
about yourself because it's
like, first of all, it's faster
than calling someone
and standing around and
pretending to watch him do it.
And it's cheaper.
It does make you feel connected
to your home in a
different way.
But during this whole time that
I was doing this, I also
was making this list for my son
of advice of things that I
had experienced, things
people had said to me.
And in the end, what I'd learned
from doing this book
is that what I learned from
writing my column in "Time"
magazine, which is that the only
real way to change is by
doing stuff.
I've become 10% manlier.
If I kept doing this stuff, I
think I would really change.
But I've been lazy.
And so I thought about
this list.
In the end, it's a really
good list and I'm
really proud of it.
But in the end, I decided
not to give it to him.
Because the only way
a man learns is by
doing, not by reading.
So I don't think he'll
ever see that list.
But I'll put it up online,
I don't care.
Is there anything I could
possibly tell you about either
my job, my book,
or my sex life?
My use of Google to improve
my sex life?
AUDIENCE: So in your experiences
through the book--
JOEL STEIN: Mohawks, no.
Not manly.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: What was the most
physically demanding and what
was the most mentally
demanding?
JOEL STEIN: The Army
was by far the
most mentally demanding.
It wasn't even close.
The most physically
demanding--
Army boot camp.
The Marine boot camp was
a tiny bit harder.
But even the Marine boot camp,
I was an old man doing stuff
meant for young men.
I passed everything.
I can't even really swim and
I got to level three of the
Marine swimming test out of I
think four without knowing
what it was or trying.
The Army stuff was like, for
the most part-- some
of it was very hard.
But for the most part,
it's like three
hard workouts a day.
But that's all you're
doing, really.
So I didn't find that
too demanding.
The MMA stuff, the UFC fighting
stuff was really
physically demanding.
Especially the jujitsu.
But the boxing and the Muay
Thai, the kickboxing, was
really demanding.
But the MMA stuff.
I think about going to take
some MMA classes to get in
better shape.
It's an amazing workout.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOEL STEIN: Anyone else have
workout questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, me, for sure.
JOEL STEIN: OK.
No, you look great.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
JOEL STEIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: The first is it was
really interesting when you
were talking about your
experience in the Army at
night and how they play the call
to prayer, which I didn't
know about.
So why do they do that?
AUDIENCE: Oh, America
hates Muslims.
And we express it
wherever we can.
I don't know if you've
noticed this.
Why did they play the--
over and over again, they try
and replicate the current
battles that were going on.
So they have a whole
fake village.
Both the Marines and the
Army have fake--
back then, fake Iraqi villages,
where they hired
like local Arabs to
play the bad guys.
So yeah.
The thing about the army that
I didn't like was you're
constantly reminded that the
job is killing people.
And for me, that's
a deal breaker.
Like if I had gotten to "Time"
and they said, you get to
write about yourself.
You have an expense account.
We're going to pay you well, but
you got to kill people, I
wouldn't have taken the job.
So for me, it was a constant
reminder that
we're killing people.
I didn't feel like they were
racist or homophobic at all.
In fact, I thought they were
very careful about it.
But they were clear about
who the enemy was.
And that involves the call
to prayers, which is--
I was surprised about, which
is why I mention and why I
wrote about it.
You should be warned.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOEL STEIN: No problem.
AUDIENCE: And my second question
was, what if your son
is like you and he
likes show tunes?
JOEL STEIN: Well, my son does
like show tunes because I play
them all the time.
And he already can sing "Singing
in the Rain," and
he's three.
So about halfway through the
book, I went from thinking, oh
my god, what if my son wants
to do this stuff?
I better know how.
Because he does.
Already, I can tell he
wants to go camping.
So now I can at least set up a
tent, take him camping, and
not be afraid.
But I also starting halfway
through, oh my god, I don't
want to raise another me.
I don't want a kid who's
afraid of everything.
I don't need him to like
all this stuff.
But I want him to at least
experience it so he knows that
he has more capabilities than he
thinks, and the world isn't
as bifurcated, or divided.
Things aren't as scary
as he thinks.
So I want him to experience
things even if he
doesn't want to.
I know you can't force
a kid to do things.
That's part of what I
learned in the book.
But yes, my son is very
much like me.
He's a total non-confrontational
wimp.
He hates sports, or throwing
a ball, or whatever the
equivalent is now.
But he loves cars and trucks.
So every kid's totally different
and I've had to
learn about--
I knew nothing about
cars and trucks.
And now I know as much
as a three-year-old
about cars and trucks.
So it's a huge improvement.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOEL STEIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So your book was about
masculinity.
Did you get any insights
about femininity from--
JOEL STEIN: Oh, I had
lots of insight.
If I have had a girl, this
would have been easy.
Did I get any extra insights
about femininity?
Yeah.
It's the same lesson I've been
learning my whole life, which
is that as much as they say they
don't, women want someone
who has some capabilities
and confidence.
And the stuff I do in the book
is stuff that like any woman
can and should do and would get
accolades for in our society--
for being able to fix a house,
being able to protect herself.
These aren't particularly
male skills.
But as a guy, if you don't
have those skills, you're
harshly judged.
Whereas, if you're a women
without those skills, society
kind of accepts that.
And that's the lesson
I kept learning.
If you don't know how to fix
stuff around your house, as
much as your wife and other
women don't care, they care.
And if you can't protect
them and protect
yourself, they care.
And that erodes your confidence
a little bit.
I grew up in the '70s and
listened to "Free to Be You
and Me" over and over again.
I was taught that there's no
difference between boys and
girls and that it's a
societal construct.
But gender is not a societal
construct.
Because my son came out like--
he could barely crawl and he
started pushing around mustard
on the ground and
making noises.
And we're like, oh, I guess we
should buy him a toy car.
And that's all he cares
about is cars.
And we were just at our
preschool open house and they
talked about like, you can put
stuff in their cubbie.
But there was something like,
don't bring Chapstick because
all the girls wind up just
using the Chapstick and
fighting over it.
And I was like, why do they
come out so differently?
You must know the
answer, right?
Isn't there some Google brain
scan that's being done on--
yeah, I'm sure.
Well, share that with
us at some point.
AUDIENCE: It is Google
Brain Scan, in fact.
JOEL STEIN: Google Brain Scan?
OK.
How far do I have to scroll down
the menu to get to that?
Because there's 8,000 things,
like streamline.
Isn't that the whole point,
it's just a bar?
It's like, oh, we do that.
We have cars that drive
themselves.
You just have to go
to the fifth page.
You just have the pass
Google+ eight
times to get to anything.
I have, by the way, 112 friends,
which I think is the
record on Google+.
So you should friend
me immediately.
AUDIENCE: From your insights and
experience with this, what
does it mean to be a man?
JOEL STEIN: Surfing is important
to being a man.
Smoking marijuana
is important.
Owning a van, having
a dog named Scooby.
Have I nailed any of
your life so far?
What does it mean to be a man?
The thing I learned the most
was having not just
self-confidence, but having
some abilities.
I feel like I'm this close
to saying the--
who's the guy who keeps
talking about skills?
The indie movie with
the kid from Utah?
Yeah, Napoleon Dynamite.
I feel like I was this close
to being Napoleon Dynamite,
talking about needing
skills, and
fighting ligers, and stuff.
But no, I think self-confidence
and
capabilities is very masculine
and very attractive.
I'd like to see you
work on that.
Also, computer science,
programming, very manly.
Engineering.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How did you find out
you wanted to be a comedy or
humor writer?
And what was it like in the
early years of your career?
JOEL STEIN: I don't play
an instrument.
I'm not good at sports.
There were very few options
for me to get attention.
And I think I developed
a sense of humor.
First of all, I'm Jewish.
And so that's kind of the
mode of communication.
And my parents think they're
funny and don't use YouTube,
so I can say that.
And I just was impressed
by the--
there was a punkishness to
comedy that really appealed to
me, because it wasn't the angry
punkishness of punk rock.
But it was kind of an inside,
self-aware kind of flipping
off the man.
And that really appealed
to me.
So I was obsessed
about Letterman.
I subscribed to "Spy"
magazine.
Letterman read one of my
questions on air when I was in
high school, which
is the highlight
of my writing career.
I tried like seven times till
I figured out how to get a
letter on Letterman.
So I didn't really think
of it as a career.
I thought I'd be a lawyer
because that's all I could
think of what people who
don't have skills do.
And so I wrote for my
high school paper.
I wrote a column.
I wrote a column for my college
paper that was far
more popular than my
column is now.
And I interned at "Newsweek"
because some professor at
Stanford who read my stuff in
the school paper got me an
internship there.
And then it started to
look more feasible.
I gave myself two years before
law school out of college.
And when those two years ended
and I still fact checking and
not writing, I decided to give
myself another two years.
And I was going to move to LA
and try sitcom writing.
That was my next two years.
I'm sure I would have found
out another two
years until I died.
And eventually, becoming some
kind of a sonnet writer.
But instead, this new
magazine, "Time
Out New York," started.
And a guy I knew from working
at Martha Stewart got a job
there and got me an interview.
It was only two years.
And to struggle for two years in
today's economy, or even in
the early '90s is amazing.
But if you don't know
it's two years, it
seems kind of endless.
It was hard.
It was hard-- and I started
not as a humor writer.
I started as a journalist.
And I tried to keep getting
people to run my column.
And I got "Time Out"
to run it.
And then when I got to "Time,"
I kept running
the "Time Out" column.
And then eventually, the editor
of "Time--" I thought
the world was much
smaller than--
even before the internet, it was
even easier to believe the
world was tiny.
So I believed that the old
people who worked at "Time"
would never see my column at
"Time Out New York," which was
incredibly stupid.
And of course, they did.
And I didn't get in trouble.
And instead Walter Isaacson, who
was my boss offered to run
my column in "Time."
And I just remember like, one
of those moments where your
adrenaline gets going and you
see the world kind of like
sharpens and shrinks.
And I remember just like,
this is crazy.
So I've basically been writing
a column since 1997 for
"Time." People think I would get
bored of it, but instead
the readers get bored.
But I keep having to find new
readers who don't get bored.
So I still really like it.
I don't think I answered any of
your questions, but I got
to talk about me.
I had a good time.
AUDIENCE: Through all the
manventures you've gone on,
have any of them kind
of stuck as hobbies?
JOEL STEIN: Hobbies, no.
And all men have hobbies, but
I don't have any hobbies.
I remember sitting down at the
cafeteria at Fort Knox, which
is where "Stripes" was
shot and I did my
fainting with the Army.
What I also learned from writing
this book is that I
can now talk to guys
in the military.
If I see a guy at
the airport--
if i saw a guy in uniform
at the airport, I never
knew what to do.
I didn't know like,
do you thank him?
Or that just annoys them?
Or do you like, offer them your
seat or is that treating
them like an old person?
I never knew how to deal.
And now I just talk to them
about where they did boot
camp, and talk about
boot camp stuff.
The Army let me fire a tank.
So I'm the first civilian to
ever fire a tank and the last
civilian who will ever
fire a tank.
So I can talk to the,
about tanks now.
What was your question again?
I'm so excited to talk
about myself.
AUDIENCE: Just if you're still
doing any of these things.
JOEL STEIN: Oh, right.
So I fix some stuff around
my house, but I
don't have a hobby.
These guys asked me if I had
hobby, because they just
wanted to connect.
The amazing thing about, no
matter how different are from
other people, if you find like
one tiny thing about their
life that you're interested in,
people are happy to talk
to you no matter how
different you are.
So the guy just wanted
to bond with me.
He was like, do you
have any hobbies?
I was like, I don't.
He's like, of course
you have a hobby.
He's like I race cars and fix
jet skis, or whatever he did.
And he had like 10 of them.
And I was like, how do
people have hobbies?
I'm either writing, cooking
dinner, or watching my kid.
Or looking at internet porn.
Is that a hobby?
And he said, no, that
wasn't a hobby.
So I'm out.
I fix stuff around my house.
And when I say that, I mean like
once every two months I
fix something--
a small thing.
So that kind of stuck.
My interest in cars stuck, but
that's only because my son.
I've learned a lot more about
cars, gotten more
interested in them.
But no, not a lot of it stuck.
And I don't know why I
don't have hobbies.
I don't know.
It just sounds so hard to have
a whole hobby, stuff you do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering
what other kinds of less
obvious manly things you might
have looked into, such as--
obvious things are like doing
the Army training, and riding
a bull, and whatever.
But some of the less obvious
things, like maybe the leader
of a boat crew that goes crab
fishing in Alaska, or doing
something like raising money
and building a startup
company, or something
like that.
Obviously, something near
and dear to us.
I'm curious about those
experience.
JOEL STEIN: Yeah.
So I sold this as a movie
and I was supposed to
write it and I haven't.
So I'm now writing it
for another guy.
And we were sitting around
yesterday making a list of
things that I considered that
we might put in the movie.
I considered Alaskan king crab
fishing, which is super manly.
In the end I decided I simply
wanted to have the skills of
your average American male,
which I defined pretty--
I think in America we define
masculinity by this very
Scotch-Irish, Sir Walter
Raleigh, South of the
Mason-Dixon line, Hatfields
and McCoys, kind of very
specific masculinity.
I was trying to do what an
average American does that
fits into that.
I also did the day trading
thing, which is a very
different Northeastern.
I was thinking about doing a
British, stiff upper lip,
drinking tea while the bombs are
falling kind of manliness.
Didn't really accomplish that.
So I really stuck to that
Southern American masculinity.
And all the things I considered
along the lines
that you're talking about,
seemed very extreme and
different than like--
I spent a day with the
firefighters in the book,
which seemed within the realm of
what an average dude might
be able to do.
Whereas like heli-logging, I
thought about having a coyote
let me cross the border
from Mexico.
I thought about doing a
couple days in prison.
I thought about joining
a biker gang or going
to Sturgis at least.
And I thought about
selling crack.
What else?
There were a couple things I
didn't do just because people
didn't call me back.
Like the Hell's Angels have
a really bad website.
I don't know if you
guys can fix that.
They don't respond to their
user questions.
Some things I got
pretty far with.
Some things I did and cut from
the book, like I actually
wound up getting all
the stuff about--
I spent a day at a
hedge fund I cut.
I spent three days as a pit crew
in this race that I cut.
I wanted to spend a couple
weeks, just occasionally at
night with the Elks, or the
Lions, or any of those groups.
Just like old dudes talking
about old stories I thought
would be something very
masculine about that
part of your life.
It was really an endless amount
of stuff I could do.
Thought about farming.
Thought about being a cowboy.
So yeah, there was really
an endless amount of
stuff I could do.
I wish I had done fewer things
actually, and really focused
more on the depth of it.
But I'm a lazy writer.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOEL STEIN: You guys
have no work to do.
AUDIENCE: Of all the different
themes and pieces that you've
researched and written about,
what made you choose this to
start writing a book?
And then, after this whole
experience, do you think
there's more in the future?
Are you interested in doing kind
of these more in-depth
pieces, and stories,
and books?
And maybe, I guess,
movies later?
JOEL STEIN: Yeah.
So after I started at "Time."
part of the reason I took that
job was so I could
write a book.
And I had one idea that was
OK that no one wanted
to buy early on.
And then, I hadn't really had
an idea I liked enough to
pursue as a book.
To be totally frank, I'm not
sure this was that idea.
It's just that the book industry
was dying and I felt
like I had to write a book.
And this was something that I
organically was talking about
and feeling.
And eventually my friend Josh
was like, you should write a
book where you learn
to be a man.
If you're so obsessed with
this, just go do it.
So it was an opportunity for me
to do a lot of things that
I wanted to have done, but
wouldn't do unless I had a
reason because they
all sucked.
So that's kind of how I decided
to write the book.
I don't know if that's
the best way to
decide to write a book.
If I were to write
another book--
I don't know.
I don't know if I would
do it the same way.
If I did do it the same way,
I know what I would write
about, which is--
I don't know if I can
describe it quickly.
But basically, I probably
won't write this book.
I'll probably have to do a new
genre of book because I think
the genre of going to do stuff
is getting a little old.
At least for now.
But if I were to go do stuff
again, I'm kind of curious
about the fact that 98% of the
decisions that we make in life
aren't really our decisions.
Because it's only practical
to do it this way.
We do what our society and
our friends are doing.
So most of the decisions I've
made about how to live my life
are really demographic and not
the thought-out choices I
would think.
So I wanted to go explore both
historically and in present
time in different cultures how
people live their lives, and
go do that for a while.
As simple as living in
a foreign country
for a couple months.
Or having my family, my parents
and my wife's parents,
live with us for a few months
as people do in most of the
world, always have done.
Just kind of exploring--
getting super religious for a
little while, just exploring
different ways to live
and seeing--
kind of making more thoughtful
choices.
I realize that didn't
sound funny, but
it'd be really funny.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that it's
unless somebody has a
burning, burning question.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOEL STEIN: Thanks
for having me.
This was fun.
[APPLAUSE]